hey youtubers it's Charlie so yesterday
in my arrow streets of fire of you I see
to submit all of your questions about
the big moments season 3 and the flash
so I picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question we also
got official news about the flash TV
show and a couple other shows too so
I'll talk about that first if you're
finding me for the first time I just do
arrow videos every week once it goes off
the air and now that we know that the
flash is gonna be a real TV show I'll
just alternate you know flash arrow
bonus videos so because I do Q&A videos
for both of those I might combine some
of them too be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave me suggestions for
future bonus videos to do so big news
first the flash has officially been
ordered to series I'm totally not
surprised but we might be getting a
trailer next week during the arrow
finale so be sure to watch it live if we
do get the trailer I'll make that my
bonus video for Wednesday I'll do a
separate video for the trailer itself
there also plug going to use that
trailer to announce which day the show
is going to air on I would guess that
it's probably going to be back-to-back
with arrow season 3
they'll just air it on the same day I'm
also expecting them to air the pilot
episode at Comic Con so if that happens
I'll be sure to post a non-spoilery
review also in slightly related
superhero TV show news while I was
pulling together the questions for this
they renewed agents of shield for season
2 and Marvel picked up the agent Carter
TV series that's gonna be around Peggy
Carter and Hayley Atwell will be
reprising the role I'll talk more about
those shows next Tuesday whenever I do
my Marvel videos because agents of
shield has its finale then it was really
funny because Disney and Warner Brothers
just both decided to dump all that news
today but onto questions
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but question
number 1 Dylan alia asks do you think
that they'll ever start calling Oliver
green arrow instead of just arrow no I
don't think the show's ever gonna use
that green part
there's definitely been an evolution to
his identity since season 1 he started
out as the vigilante then became the
arrow remember in the episode when
Quentin was talking to his sergeant the
sergeant called Oliver the vigilante and
Quentin corrected him saying the arrow I
think more people will just start
thinking of him less as a vigilante and
more as a force for good but even Batman
was never perceived as a 100% good guy
the whole beauty of being the arrow is
that Oliver can walk the line of Justice
you know more
the police he's never gonna be like
Superman who you know say Batman
actually calls the Boy Scout like
Oliver's never gonna be that Boy Scout
person question number two sapphire-blue
asks what do you think about the photo
from the next episode where Slade is
taking Felicity hostage yeah it's a
really nice teaser for you know Slade
killing the person Oliver loves most but
if you remember might you know female
algebra that I did in my review video he
loves all of them equally so he doesn't
love any of the women the most so
technically it's a bit of a fake out
Slade is gonna kill a ton of people in
the episode anyway so Felicity probably
just gets snagged in the crossfire
during a moment there were some behind
the scenes images that they shot at a
water treatment facility with a bunch of
pipes so I'm guessing that's where that
scene takes place but I have no idea
what that location is doubling for maybe
some sort of power plant Felicity has
already been confirmed for season three
so obviously she has to make it out of
that situation somehow and the list of
people that could actually legitimately
die in the finale is pretty small
question number three David Alvarado
asks do you think that Quentin will be
the Commissioner next year and Laurel
could be the District Attorney so I
don't think that Quentin's going to be
the commissioner he'll just be a regular
detective but I do think that Laurel
will become the district attorney
there's also a lot of black Canary's
Sarah dying talk going on but even if
Laurel does become the Black Canary in
season three I think that it's gonna
take all season for her to get there
like she won't become the Black Canary
till the end of the season she's not
just gonna show up in episode 1 in black
leather I think what we'll see though is
her stepping into a position of more
power where she can help team arrow you
know help them prosecute the super
criminals that they take down so team
arrow will just become much more
effective because remember Quentin is
also now back in a position of power so
I think they'll just work together as a
team a little bit better question number
4 Kim asks do you think there's a
possibility that Merlyn could help out
team arrow
yes he's actually marching next to them
in the trailer for the finale
Oliver still has a lot of unfinished
business with him and Thea does not like
him at all so I don't think Merlin's
gonna be a good guy from now on they'll
just have a temporary truce while they
deal with the shitstorm I have seen a
lot of rumors that Merlyn could be the
season 3 villain I don't know if they're
true but remember Isabel talked about
the sins of the father whenever she
revealed her true plan to Oliver so I
like that idea continuing into season 3
the thing about the plot threads that
they start each season is that they all
have to connect by the finale for
instance the one common denominator this
season is Oliver in Slade's of
relationship so in season three I really
like the idea of Felicity's relationship
with her father or Thea's being the
common denominator and don't forget
Oliver has a son so since the father has
a whole new meaning now fathers and sons
fathers and daughters I feel like that
equation would work a lot better if
Oliver child turned out to be a little
girl so that it would just all be
Father's relationships with their
daughters which is funny because in real
life Stephen Amell has a baby girl
question number five Marvel DC asks how
do you think that Roy will react when
every wakes up he's probably just gonna
be really horrified with what he's done
especially to Thea I think he'll spend
most of season 3 trying to repair that
relationship and just atone for the
crimes against the city those demons
will probably be what motivates him to
be a hero and yes I don't think he's
gonna have super strength or super
healing anymore he'll be back to normal
Oliver is like the benchmark for hero on
the show he's a totally normal person
with no superpowers and he still does
the work of a superhero just like the
other Justice League team members it's
the same thing with Batman you know non
superhero doing the work of a superhero
so Roy is just gonna jump on that train
in season 3 question number 6 Jose asks
do you think that Oliver should take the
mirakuru no I mean I actually kind of
explained why in that previous question
but let's talk about the consequences of
what would happen if he did take it so
far no one has been immune to the mental
side effects so if Oliver took it he'd
succumb to that madness - he probably
hallucinate his father if you remember
he actually spent most of season one on
the island hallucinating him he probably
turned into like a Frank Castle Punisher
and just start murdering supervillains
and Amanda Waller would end up having to
nuke the city all over again Slade and
Oliver basically the same person only
Slade went to the dark side and Oliver
became Luke Skywalker I am still waiting
to see if Oliver can redeem Darth Slade
by the end of the finale or if he's
gonna end up having to throw him down an
elevator shaft question number 7 said in
a masks they keep destroying the city
each season did they even fully rebuild
it after the undertaking that's actually
a good point no they did not
the glades that was actually the part
that was blown up the city basically
ended up getting worse and that's what
brother blood built his campaign for
mayor on he was like this is a problem
that no one cares about but me I'll fix
it so the city itself is still broken
now they're breaking it again and even
if Amanda Waller doesn't nuke it which I
don't think she is Slade's army has
still trashed it so I think in season
three Queen industries and Oliver is
gonna be a big part of repairing that
the thing that they have not addressed
yet is how is Oliver going to get his
company back I'm really hoping that they
deal with that in the finale question
number eight Sam Hockney asks do you
think that Thea will learn Oliver's
identity I certainly hope so
I mean she knows Merlin's identity and
what he's done so she's basically
halfway there she even started to
question the connection between Slade
and Oliver so I'm hoping that Oliver
does the same thing with her that he did
with Roy you know where he rips his mask
off and makes a really passionate speech
right now Merlin's with Thea and
obviously he's marching with them in
that trailer for the finale so they have
to meet up at some point I'm really
looking forward to that reunion you know
Oliver still does not know that Merlin
is alive question number nine and T a
critic asks what other kind of trick
arrows do you think that Oliver will use
in the future I actually think that
they're going to attach the mirakuru
cure to Oliver and Merlin's arrow tips
so technically that's kind of like a
trick arrow I think you're asking about
regular trick arrows though
realistically he could use EMP arrows
like Hawkeye did and Avengers and
Stephen Amell even said that he wants to
use more trick arrows so don't be
surprised that there are a few new ones
in the next season I don't think we've
seen a zipline arrow in a while so we
might see that next to question number
ten keys masks
do you think they'll change Oliver's
costume or as look in season three no
not really not in a significant way
usually the lead actors are the ones
that change the least they're like the
through line for the whole series so for
the most part they need to change the
least at least from a physical
standpoint and think about it this way
if Oliver gets rid of those leather
pants
Felicity won't be able to make fun of
them anymore and one last bonus question
KJ pukana asks what DC superhero do you
want to see get a TV show next gosh
there are so many they have in
development I think realistically
Suicide Squad would be next but if I got
to pick any one I would say Deathstroke
Vandal Savage
it would definitely have to be a villain
we've seen so many new hero shows now
it's time to see a villain get their own
show
if it were Vandal Savage it could be
like an injustice society show and if it
were Nyssa al Ghul it could be like
League of Assassins
in reality it's much more likely that
we'll get a spin-off show for a
character that's already been
established on arrow or another
superhero show but thank you so much for
submitting your questions these videos
are always a ton of fun to do so be on
the lookout for a very special cameo in
the finale and that flash trailer if we
do get the trailer that's what I'm gonna
make my bonus video so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and right
now click here to get my review of the
episode and click here to learn about my
brand new bonus gaming channel that's
right I spun off a channel just for
gaming videos thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you